I'll be back oh hell yeah they will be
this new addition to the Terminator
franchise promises the action we know
and love or if you've never seen a
t-1000 shape-shift here's everything you
need to know before you go it's a direct
sequel to the first two movies but it's
30 years later so there's this there's a
darkness at night that's right for this
Terminator film you can ignore the last
three terminator rise of the machines
Terminator Salvation and terminator
genisys as well as the TV show the Sarah
Connor Chronicles so let's start with
the basics
this film franchise deals with time
travel apocalyptic warfare and synthetic
intelligence in the original Terminator
Arnold Schwarzenegger plays a cyborg
sent back in time to kill Sarah Connor
to prevent the birth of her future son
John John Connor is destined to lead the
resistance in the future against all
cyborgs Kyle Reese a human soldier was
also sent back in time what day is it
to date 12th May 3rd day what year to
protect Sarah but fell in love with her
on his mission he learned of Sarah from
her son John in their attempts to stay
alive Sarah's feelings for Kyle grow and
she becomes pregnant with his child
unfortunately Kyle dies while trying to
keep her safe all of this is tricky
because you see Sarah is pregnant with
John who will grow up to meet and
befriend Kyle in the future should I
tell you about your father if you don't
send Kyle you could never be and
naturally she struggles with whether or
not she will tell her son about Kyle
someday the sequel Terminator 2 Judgment
Day takes place in 1995 John Connor is a
young boy living with foster parents
while his mother Sarah is imprisoned in
a mental hospital for attempting to bomb
a computer factory she's been preparing
him throughout his childhood to lead the
resistance Arnold is back to the
previous cyborg that he played known as
Terminator t800 in the first film died
who sent you 35 years from now you
reprogrammed me to be your protector
here
this time the Terminator and John breaks
Sarah out and she learns about Skynet
the company and network that created
these cyborgs and the destruction
they've caused in the future all the
while another more elite cyborg that
t1000 is sent back to kill John the evil
cyborg goes back in time to prevent John
from ruining their plans for Judgment
Day the day that Skynet will enact a
nuclear holocaust wiping out all humans
so Sarah takes matters into her own
hands and goes after its founder Miles
Bennett Dyson Skynet Judgment Day the
history of things to come it's not every
day that you find out you're responsible
for three billion deaths they convinced
him to destroy the materials that will
lead to the apocalypse in the future and
unfortunately this includes the
Terminator so now that you're up to
speed
let's consider a few things it's awesome
to see Linda back on the big screen the
person choice at the end of the second
was so wildly different from the one at
the end of the first and then who does
she become after thirty years of living
like that and that idea was so explored
did she really prevent Judgment Day what
does this mean for the fate of the world
we see a grayed out and aged model t800
but didn't he die in the end of
Terminator 2 in an interview with
director Tim Miller were told that
Arnold is a new Terminator with a new
past we go through the
with the p800 adopting human behavior
we've also got some new faces in the
film Mackenzie Davis plays grace an
enhanced human soldier from the future
Natalia beiow says Dani Ramos a
character whose fate is similar to Sarah
Connor we also got a new villain cyborg
the rebbe 9 that is focused on killing
Danny played by Gabriel Luna his powers
and capabilities they're pretty damn
spectacular James Cameron is also back
as producer and co-writer of the film he
had no hand in guiding the story of The
Terminator films after Judgment Day so
it makes sense the dark fate picks up
where Terminator 2 left off so now you
know and now you can go see terminator
dark fate in theaters November 1st